GREG HIRSCH: Hey there, hey!
-Hey, hey sir.
-Oh, hey! Hey, excuse me.
Hey, my Sherpa, what's cooking?
Yeah, just-- Just might have
just touched Bill Gates.
Ooh, hey,
did you check out the acoustics
on my room for my talk?
And did you get me
on the culture hike?
And what did I--
What did I get in my chalet?
Did I get the nut
and fruit box,
or the champagne
and paperweight?
Nuts.
Yeah.
But, uh--
But the talk venue's great.
Uh, it's the same one
as Roman and Ken.
-Oh, okay.
-Yeah, and, um--
And don't worry about the nuts,
I mean the cashews
-are the size of boomerangs.
-(CHUCKLING) Okay.
-So...
-Thanks, man, thanks.
Oh, hey.
Nice vest, Wambsgans,
-it's so puffy.
-Thank you, Roman.
What's it stuffed with,
your hopes and dreams?
Oh, wow, hiking boots,
they're pristine.
Oh, here we go.
All right,
all rise for Pope Big Dick.
Hello, Rhea.
Mr. Roy.
You know what I need.
-Hey, hey there--
-LOGAN ROY: Hi.
Yeah, uh, just to say,
I don't know how up-to-speed
you are, with all the details,
but, um, just say that
we're all lined up for
the ATN strategy announcement.
Yeah, same shit,
different wrapper.
(STUTTERING) We're not gonna--
we're not gonna go
with that banner, but we--
Yeah, we settled on,
"We're Listening."
It tested great.
It tested fine.
Do me a favor.
Is that Sandy Furness?
-Uh...
-Oh, yes. Yes, yes.
Keep talking, keep talking.
HIRSCH: Oh, yeah.
I don't want to bump him,
not here, not now.
-TOM WAMBSGANS: Okay.
-The vipers would love it.
HIRSCH: Well, gladly--
We'd be honored
-to be your talking partners.
-WAMBSGANS: Yes.
And so basically the talk
is a celebration
of putting audience input
front-and-center,
and hopefully
be really inclusive
and quite change-y
after recent events.
Because ATN Citizen
is essentially very similar,
but with the option
of new--
How's he-- How's he looking?
Is he healthy?
-Uh... not really.
-Uh, he looks...
-he looks a little enfeebled.
-Yeah, yeah.
I heard-- I heard maybe...
maybe syphilis.
-Whoa.
-What? Really?
-And that's deadly.
-Interesting.
'Cause you don't really hear
much about syphilis these days.
Very much the, uh--
the MySpace of STDs.